è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj e oggi siamo
tornati su tolgo dismount c'è
meraviglioso ragazzi specialmente come
la posizione del mio mino in questo
momento lunghe reazione ho amato alla
follia sconcio con la primo episodio che
ci ho fatto e quindi dovevo
assolutamente farci un seguito perché
merita troppo farò marcio è fantastico
che cazzo sta succedendo lo permette ok
perfetto ed è così che parcheggio erano
rimasti siamo fatti i primi cinque mi
pare quindi devo fare gli ultimi quattro
che sono sicuro che saranno meravigliosi
infatti questo avevo provato prime
atomica che partenza verso l'infinito il
successo regalo a fermi sono incastrato
e solo a me possono succedere se
puttanate assurde perché non ha senso
ok perche ci siamo ok la macchina andata
a punta
signore e signori l'autostrada rimarrà
inagibile perché prevedo un po di
traffico sull'a4 tra granata catturata
dal terrazzo spiega siamo messi
malissimo
buongiorno vigile fa vj come dirigere il
traffico questo è sexy lega questo è
fottutamente sexy è una cosa oddio
eccolo lì perfetto perfetto ci siamo a
rischio che rubare da sottiletta
schiacciata
fatemi cambiare veicolo perché con
questi guardare ecco vediamo con la moto
se riusciamo a fare qualcosa di decente
minchia che cazzo c'è ma avete presente
james bond
mi fa una pippa ma quanto è bello andare
in giro con le ali che forse non ce l'ho
leali pro cazzo eccola lì per te
qualcosa mi dice che c'è bisogno di un
po di fi di un chirurgo estetico adesso
noi no cazzo cazzo ragazzi il freno
amarmi è partito freno a mano dai tagli
t party frena bacheca
così si sono vivo
sono vivo per miracolo io gli ho sempre
desiderato vedere una scena del genere
nella mia vita perché sono cose che ti
segnano nel profondo
eccolo lì perfetto magari se rimango non
rimanga cosa mi dice che non rimango
ecco l'attrice parcheggiato da dio come
va a fare la spesa un vero boss
c'è chi va a fare la spesa normalmente
noi io ci vado così perché è meglio e
fatti fa più figo dai eccolo lì il
carrello né partito non so dove hanno
ritrovato could be king stan ma non
importa
e me ne vado dall'altra parte [ __ ]
eccolo lì lo sapevo ma come mila un
passaggio razzi è molto gentile
la mia batmobile tornerà a prendermi
perché ne sono sicuro
eccola e ma allora sei stronza forte ok
ma sta macchina dove i miei ragazzi così
da domani voglio vederli tutti guidare
così che belle le giornate di cui ben
che stronza ma lasciati indietro cazzo
mento metto questa minchia rega
voglio provare a fare dio e così vaga
tenetevi pronti per il salto più antico
della storia se ci riesco voglio un
oscar
madonna vai così c'è ma si può ai così
con questa ci riesco perché questa è una
signora macchina fucà ecco la moto si
con la voto si crolla non è ma che
questo è il salto più assurdo della
storia non si riesce con niente guarda
che merda ma perché ma perché è il mio
dio ti sta bene non niente non so
neanche investito ragazzi la vedo
malissimo ma ci voglio provare così con
te perché non riesco a farlo con niente
è impossibile una roba ecco lo sapevo
grazie grazie grazie grazie veramente
ma se riuscissi a prendere una
maledettissima curva decente all'inizio
magari sul camion
guarda che non ci posso crederlo
bravissimo si si lo prezzo sopra almeno
l'ho presa let's keep going ragazzi
propone un altro prima che cos'è che
cazzo è un suicidio non fermi io volevi
volevo bene in una maniera che non avete
idea però non lo sapevo che era un
suicidio perfetto ma se ci sono molti
riciclo nostra cosa dopo la requisitoria
ragazzi vi ho voluto bene in una maniera
che non immaginate però è giunta la mia
ora bellissima grandi eccolo lì che si
sbilancia nelle maniere più incredibile
ma che cazzo di vino è questo certi
suicidi e basta no no ma c'è posso
mettersi posso mettere la rampa ragazzi
sta cosa voglio farla con questo
comunque eccola lì ci siamo ragazzi ci
siamo sì ma oggi porca [ __ ] non è
giornata i ragazzi primo giro a
gardaland ci siamo ecco questa è la
giostra che mi piace
ecco che vedete gira tranquillamente
merda merda ecco ci siamo
perfetto lo so ho vinto un cazzone esami
fatti di provare l'ultimo skara mega
skara scaramanga scaramal cos'è ragazzi
cioè mi che ho visto qualcosa di
stupendo e orgasmi casta mappa
bellissimo ragazzi di chi sa che salto
di merda però non riuscì a farlo
decentemente confermi che questo volevo
fare bene sta cosa non penso si possa
fare
è assurdo come fai a fare non c'entrano
mai di più quel punto c'è la volta che
riuscirò a fare una cosa del genere mi
informo santo credo con che criterio
dovrei riuscire a prendere st curva ma
non c'è mai
mica che porta in modo decente non è
possibile si no caputo rimasto impalato
ragazzi è rimasto impalato minchia c'ero
quasi zero fottutamente quasi con un
fatto sopravvivere si così perfetto così
mi dicono che diana
non sono neanche partito merda forse
così ragazzi ma non penso di riuscire è
cosa
[Musica]
si no no non ci credo ma guarda che
schifo alla fine alla fin dove vai vieni
qui vieni dov'è andato che vai storto ma
perché ma cos'è sto schifo
la cosa brutta è che sto coso ma storto
parte dritto poi finalmente cazzo se
magari mani sulla moto è meglio se non
riuscissimo a cadere ogni tre secondi
per motivi insulsi tipo questo
ora li mortacci sua ma guarda che cazzo
è come lo ridotta la moto tanto ormai
non food stato ha capito la casa e non
funziona un cazzo minchia che velocità
al massimo lodata sì sì
c'è
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta anni per riuscirci
minchia ragazzi sono sono un uomo
completo da oggi ci ho messo anni anni
per fare sto schifo è una cosa assurda
ci ho messo anni ai soli con i tre
secondi volevo provare a fare freeway
l'ultima volta perché volevo provare a
buttare giù il muro se riesco commesso
io a metà perché una cosa invalicabile
si lavava sporca [ __ ] cielo quasi
eccolo lì perfetto mi mancava stare su
un parabrezza avevo la nostalgia
adottare un po di colla grazie sì sì no
no non è caduto come cazzo non è caduto
non ne fossi cadi cadi
non ci credo mezz'ora per fare un
livello mezz'ora ragazzi non è possibile
ci ho messo anni per fare una cosa così
già ditemi se è normale
vabbè io direi che possono concludere
che i ragazzi perché è stata
un'esperienza traumatica e alla fine
ragazzi sto gioca una droga perché mi
viene da fare i salti in una maniera
incredibile ma io ti amo
ho buttato giù un cubo 1 non è possibile
ragazzi io direi che posso concludere
qui perché sono oggi non è giornata di
fatti evidentemente ma non importa
quindi se il video vi è piaciuto lo
stato un commento mi piace anche a
facili facebook e con i video tratte
nella descrizione c'era se la faresti
iscrivetevi non ci diventare nel
prossimo vinto da ragazzi
[Musica]